bonsoir le 7 8 sur tv fils une heure
pour faire le tour complet de
l'actualité locale en direct du lundi au
jeudi en ce 26 mars nous allons donc
recevoir sur le plateau plusieurs
invités et tout d'abord le ronge cousin
bonsoir vous êtes adjointe à la
direction divine information jeunesse
dont les locaux se trouvent à versailles
on va parler de votre actualité une
permanence sur l'alternance dès demain
mercredi et puis un forum le 10 avril
avec pour mot d'ordre l'europe c'est
possible qu'il s'agisse d'étudier ou
d'exercer un job saisonnier
ce soir également comme chaque mardi la
chronique de l'environnement avec julie
rocha soirée sponsors julie bonsoir donc
ce soir nous allons parler de la
programmation très riche autour de la
semaine du développement durable qui
débute le 2 avril dans plusieurs
structures de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
recevront deux invités amelio baer de la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux et yoann girbaud de l' agence
locale de l'énergie et du climat de ce
canton ni film la chronique de
l'environnement dans une vingtaine de
minutes et puis à noter aussi que les
organisateurs du city raid à montigny le
bretonneux et de la course du printemps
à voisins le bretonneux nous rejoindront
un peu plus tard citoyenneté et sport
donc au programme de la prochaine heure
voici les titres à présent les sujets à
suivre elle l'a compris la concertation
autour de l'aménagement de la zac que
charles renard à saint cyr l'école et
dans quelques années sortiront de terre
1500 logements et des équipements
publics elle les habitants sont invités
à faire part de leurs réflexions
le département des yvelines consacre
chaque année 7 millions d'euros pour
l'aide à l'accueil d'urgence des
adolescents visite du centre
départemental 90% des placements sont
demandés par les juges le harlem shakes
est dense déjanté et déguisés tout le
monde s'y met depuis ce mercredi il faut
aussi compter sur les étudiants de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines ils étaient une centaine
devant la bibliothèque universitaire à
l'appel du bureau des étudiants a
fortiori et puis le parc naturel de la
haute vallée de chevreuse qui vient de
lancer son opération nettoyage de
printemps armés de sacs les habitants
sont invités ramasse
les déchets prochaine ville est concerné
manille les armes l'actualité de ce 26
mars c'est aussi les étudiants de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui reçoivent en ce moment
si vous nous suivez en direct le
rapporteur de la loi sur le mariage pour
tous
nous allons tout de suite faire le point
ce rassemblement ces discussions qui
semblent plutôt compliqué détention qui
commencent à poindre
du côté de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en ce moment erwann binet
le rapporteur de la loi sur le mariage
pour tous qui sera examiné début avril
au sénat est l'invité des étudiantes de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une rencontre
débat dont vous allez voir dans un
instant les premières images cette
réunion a débuté à 17 heures et sur
place anthony rech bonsoir anthony pour
la rédaction de télé fils anthony cette
réunion qui commençait plutôt bien
qu'ils aient finalement été suspendu des
opposants au projet de loi sur le
mariage pour tous qui ont décidé de
s'immiscer dans les discussions avec les
étudiants oui ça fait à peu près 20
minutes après 40 minutes de débat entre
les professeurs de la faculté émeutiers
en guinée et bien une trentaine de
personnes sont arrivées se sont immiscés
dans l'amphithéâtre avec des slogans
comme aux pirates aloi on n'en veut pas
ou ils se sont mis à chanter tout
simplement la marseillaise une ambiance
très électrique est devenu envahir tout
simplement le l'amphithéâtre pardo les
manifestants étaient sortis et malgré
par la police et aaron vie n'ait été
évacués par les renseignements généraux
dont il n'y aura pas de débat ne vont
pas se poursuivre cette réunion
organisée par les étudiants a été tout
simplement annulée suspendus pour
l'instant à l'équipe en u à wang bin est
toujours dans les locaux de la rue qui
de droit de l'université de versailles
saint quentin on ne sait pas quand elle
que cela va reprendre les vieux ça va
reprendre le à l'heure actuelle où je
vous parle je suis dans la rue devant
l'amphithéâtre à l'extérieur en fait de
la fac
les policiers ont dispersé un petit peu
la foule qui s'est à peu près calme et
met les étudiants sont toujours là et
attendre peut-être un éventuel retour
des débats mais rien n'est certain
le rappel en cette réunion est organisée
par des étudiants de l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
la faculté de droit réunion qui débutait
à 17h les débats étaient en train de se
dérouler si vous nous suivez en direct à
18h ils n'ont pas pu se poursuivre avec
une intervention des forces de police
tout simplement
on peut peut-être appelé juste pour
conclure anthony qui avait organisé
cette réunion et puis dans quel but
également tout simplement dit l'étudiant
de la faculté de droit de l'université
après 50 ans le bd eu un très
précisément le bureau des étudiants et
il avait fait venir donc erwann binet
pour débattre et surtout discuter des
points juridiques importants qui pose
problème de ce projet de loi taubira
merci anthony pour ces précisions je le
rappelle si vous nous suivez en direct
nous sommes mardi les 18 heures et la
réunion organisée à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
avec erwann binet rapporteur de la loi
sur le mariage pour tous à l'assemblée
qui n'a pas pu se poursuivre nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur cette
information
la donne notre édition de demain un peu
plus tôt dans la journée les étudiants
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
était dans une toute autre ambiance
autre atmosphère toujours cette
association le bureau des étudiants a
fortiori qu'ils avaient décidé
d'organiser à harlem shakes vous le
savez cette danse très populaire sur
internet où il faut venir plutôt
déguisez vous allez voir les images du
tournage c'était cet après midi devant
la bibliothèque universitaire environ
200 étudiants étaient présents
près de 200 étudiants de l'ue vs qu
attendait ce mardi après-midi les
directives pour commencer par harlem
shakes cette danse conceptuel qui fait
le buzz sur internet et nous vient des
états unis
c'est une amie en fait on en fit qui
regardait une vidéo comme ça sur un
petit concours bon c'est pas très
sérieux mais voilà est quelqu'un de
notre staff bd a fortiori la repérer il
s'est dit pourquoi pas pourquoi pas le
faire donc c'est romain vergé qui
l'avait qui l'a repéré ça et pourquoi
pas le faire et pourquoi pas nous aussi
organisée à l'issue de ce conseil que
les étudiants sont en demande de
d'événements comme ça sourit quand son
emploi juste sur la musique pop du
compositeur bauer un danseur est chargé
d'entraîner les personnes autour de lui
d'abord passible dans une chorégraphie
déjanté pendant que les étudiants saint
quentinois se place sous l'oeil de
nombreux curieux
le solitaire partage son état d'esprit
je la sens bien un peu stressé mais ça
va être très marrant là je vais dégainer
une panse qui s'appelle la danse de
l'épaule
une danse qui n'a eu ni queue ni tête du
monde et bien action
les goûts
toujours